each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi everybody thank you for coming this
is a chris olson he's coming here from
yahoo research and today he's going to
give us a talk about some of the work
he's done in web scale processing and
Aldiss I think let him get going on that
thank you very much thanks Chris okay
thanks I'm like yeah so so I'm here to
talk about pig and the you'll know what
I just soon enough so I have a sort of a
complicated diagram that I draw to
motivate the work so this is going to
require your attention inside the
rectangle so like what so you know
there's been a lot of excitement lately
about the need to just in general deal
with very large data sets and all the
ramifications but that has and certainly
yahoo and google and microsoft a lot of
you know but there's sort of bit you
know the engine of innovation so to
speak a lot of it comes from taking very
large data sets being able to analyze
them and derive new knowledge and
exploit that and make money and right so
so this work is sort of part of the
overall sort of theme of the last few
years of people trying to figure out
ways to derive value out of very large
data sets using large-scale systems okay
so in a little bit more detail than my
last picture right so we have these
projects that are where we're trying to
you know derive data drive value from
large data sets you have two kinds of
things roughly I mean you have cases
where you have unstructured data and
you're trying to drive structure right
so we don't really do this so much i
yahoo but you know you you have images
and you want to derive you know people
from those right or maybe you have data
that's already fairly well structured
but you want to understand it better
right maybe maybe this is a very
complicated system that the data is from
so you have these complicated social
systems and economic systems and
computer systems you want to try to
understand them better right I I assume
I'm preaching to the choir here right so
we like to say data analysis was the
inner loop and I you know at least for
some part of Microsoft was probably the
same thing
and as we all know so now you have big
data you want to do big processing
parallelism is the name of the game okay
so some concrete examples that I'm going
to use sort of as running examples
throughout the talk and the first one is
sort of the hello world kind of
equivalent it is very very simple just
you know brain-dead parallelism is that
you have some function you want to run
it end times and as big each invocation
is independent right very simple a
slightly less simple one is you okay so
you have some web data like you've
crawled the web and you've recorded
people's clicks so you have these two
big data sets and there are lots of
interesting analyses you can do over
these data sets but I'm just going to
pick one as an example you you're
interested in finding sessions of
consecutive clicks by a given user and
you want to find sessions where the last
page it was clicked on was better than
the others according to some metric of
goodness okay so just you know these are
the kinds of things we want to be able
to do and you know we're not the first
people by any means to work on these
kind of problems so there's obviously
just there's work from the hardware to
the software side parallel architectures
and you know people have looked at data
parallel software for many decades
parallel databases may produce dry it of
course done at Microsoft and then of
course even on the language side sequel
is you know they two parallel language
from a long time ago there's stuff from
the programming languages community on
data parallelism okay so what you know
what we're doing is is is building on a
lot of the existing technologies and
trying to do something that that really
fulfills us sort of a sweet spot that we
see in the way people are processing big
data sets at Yahoo and I suspect that
generalizes not only to the other three
Jim companies but to you know the
sciences and government and all of these
areas where people are dealing with very
large data sets so um but you know as I
go I'll make references to this this
large body of friar work so that the
project is called pig don't ask me why
it just as um pigs on usually people
think pig is an acronym it's not it's
just a farm animal but
so there are two aspects to the to the
project okay there's we have a data
parallel language the language is called
Pig leiden and roughly speaking it's the
combination of these three aspects that
make it powerful and make it useful and
as you'll see on the talk people
actually do use this a lot of Yahoo so
the first is that we have relational
style primitives for manipulating data
so if you don't know what that means
it's like filter and join and sort of
set oriented primitives okay and the the
style of programming is more of an
imperative sort of step-by-step style
okay which is different from what you
see with sequel and the third thing is
that we make it very easy to plug in
custom processing right and you can you
can interoperate with legacy code all
those things which in practice makes a
big difference okay so it's the
combination of those three aspects that
make it work well in practice and I'll
talk about the language and sort of the
first half of the talk and then I will
talk about our implementation which is
called Pig and there's a lot of
boilerplate stuff here which I won't
bore you with but I will talk about some
stuff that's a little bit more in the
research side that has to do with
optimizing ensembles of programs okay so
i'll get to that more at the end so
starting with the language and so
remember our simple detect faces and
images example okay and so here's a very
simple Pig program that is going to take
a set of images potentially very large
set of images and do face detection okay
and I'm going to walk you through it my
goal is not for you to understand the
syntax because you can look it up in our
syntax manual but just to give you a
flavor for how the language works so
don't don't focus too much on small
details of the syntax but the basic idea
is that there are three lines okay each
line represents a distinct command right
and that is a distinct operation on data
the first one is simply specifying where
the input to the computation is going to
come from right so you're saying load
you're giving a pointer to a file or
maybe a directory containing a set of
files in some underlying file system
that could either be a local file system
or could be a distributed file system
like the Google file system or the
Hadoop file system okay here you're
specifying some code that is able to
parse this file or set of files
into structured records and here you're
actually specifying what that structure
is you're saying well it's a bunch of
pairs of ID and then the bytes of the
image okay and then the assignment on
the left you're saying well i'm going to
create a variable called I which stands
for the set of all such records that
were extracted from this file okay and
so on the left side i'm going to have
these variables that stand four sets of
records okay it's important to realize
that these variables are not
instantiated anywhere they're just
conceptual okay so so fine so I is sort
of the parts of data set and then the
next command is saying well look I want
to apply some operation on each instance
each member of that set and in
particular I want to run my detect faces
code on it on the image and then I also
want to pass along the ID so i know
which image i came from okay so f is
just going to be the set of ID and you
know face detection output pairs okay
and then the last line is I'm saying
well I want to take the set F and I want
actually materialize it in my file
system okay and if I do it like this
it'll just use some default formatting
if I want to have some custom way of
laying it out on the in the file i can
write similarly with the input here i
can specify some code that will lay it
out however i want right and the sort of
these input and output code things are
very important in practice because they
help you interpret what other tools okay
so but this is supposed to be simple
hopefully everyone understands this one
so we can get to the next one any
questions about this one okay okay great
so that's simple so here's a slightly
more complicated one remember we had
this notion of sessions that we wanted
to find sessions that end with the best
page so you've got these two very large
data sets one is a data size of visits
of users to web pages so you've got
these triples let's say you know Amy
went to CNN at 8am this is all
fictitious of course and then you've got
this other data set which is all the all
the web pages in the universe right so
you've crawled like 10 to the 10th web
pages and for each page you you you can
extract all kinds of information from
that page right you have many columns
just for now let's assume that you've
extracted just the page rank of each
page you've computed the page rank right
and so you have these two data sets and
obviously if you combine them you can
answer that question let's define the
best page as being the one with the
highest page rank and let's define a
session as being a sequence of clicks by
the same user that are not divided by
more than an hour right okay so look you
know if you shoot if you read some some
old books or papers on parallel
algorithms you know from like the 80s
you can figure out how to do this in
parallel right you take you take it you
know let's let's assume that these
visits and pages data sets are large so
we're going to initially store them on
instead of on one disks on an array of
disks so we'll have like a thousand this
each storing point one percent of the
visits 1,000 does each storing point one
percent of pages and write fundamentally
to answer this question we need to be
able to associate page ranks with the
clicks right and then we can actually do
the processing so the first step the
data sort of flowing up here in this
diagram the first step is we need to do
do that matching of you know pages with
visits according to the URLs right and
in databases is called a join and you
know one way to do it there are many
ways to do it but one way to do it is
you you allocate like a thousand compute
nodes that's what these these boxes
represent and you take a one record out
of here and you send it to one of these
places right by looking at the URL maybe
applying a hash function or some other
function right you do the same thing
over here such that you know records
with the same URL are going to
rendezvous with the same node over here
right there probably most of you seen
things like this before okay and so what
happens is all the CNN records go over
here all the BBC records go over here
you do the matching locally after that
point right so not so now you know the
page ranks of every click the problem is
now you've mixed up all the data based
on URL what you really wanted to know
was for each user what was you know what
were these sessions right so then let's
find so we're computer scientist so
we'll just use the same trick again so
allocate a bunch of nodes up here will
redistribute the data such that all of
the user all of Amy's records are here
although Fred's records are here once
we've done that the rest is all local
right we can we can apply some session
ization here stick to Amy's clicks and
then we can look at you know there's a
very simple script and you any of us can
write it like five
lines that tells you is the last click
in a session the one with the highest
page rank or not okay so fine so you
know parallel algorithm it will be
really fast even if the data is big okay
obviously what we're going after here is
that we want you know we want things to
execute in this manner but we don't want
to write this code we wouldn't want to
write the distributed code because it's
hard to write and it's even harder to
debug right so this is a pig latin
program that causes the execution that i
showed you on the previous slide okay
and again my my goal is not to go over
the nitty-gritty the nitty-gritty
details of the syntax but just to give
you a flavor of how this works okay so
there are these two load commands
because we had two data sets so lets you
know say the data sets were initially in
these two directories the web is kind of
yucky so it turns out that urls you can
have many different strings that
actually semantically represent the same
page so there's this process of
canonical izing or normalizing URL
strings so let's say you have a function
that does that so what we're doing here
was once we load up the visits let's say
that we know that in that data set the
URLs have not been canonicalize so the
first thing we do is say okay for each
of these visits we want to canonicalize
the URL right so now we have the
cleaned-up visits let's say in pages
that's already stored in canonicalize
form right so the next thing we need to
do is perform this join we have a
command called join and that takes
visits and pages and here we can say we
want to join them based on URLs okay so
VP is the set of visits joined with
pages okay and then what we want to do
is we want to group those records
according to users so now we're going to
take this very large flat set of you
know visits match with pages and divide
it into subsets one for each user okay
so user visits is like the set of
subsets okay and then and then for each
of those we want to run some code that
finds sessions using our heuristic of
looking for gaps in time right and and
so now we have sessions and then lastly
we want to filter sessions which means
we're going to take us
and we're going to find a subset and
here we have some predicate some
function that returns true or false
which just looks at okay is the last you
know click that one of the highest page
rank or not okay so so what's going on
so you're simply you're invoking
transformations on sets of Records to
get new sets of Records you know this
transformations have names like loan and
group and for each I've pretty much
shown you the whole language so there's
only a handful of transformations and
this is pretty much the whole thing okay
and the power is that you have a small
amount of transformations but they're
governed by these functions that users
provide so you're doing filtering you
can filter according to either a
built-in kind of predicate or according
to a custom user function and same
similarly with drawings and with all the
other the other commands any questions
about this program in the back you're
not in the back so doesn't so why did
you not use the governor you like math
or reducing detective use join them well
but you could ask the MapReduce guys why
they didn't use relational terminology I
mean that at some level but they're all
the same yeah I just slide on that urban
okay yeah so usually something I usually
somebody asks one of each of those
questions okay so i will get to the
relationship to my produce in a second
and also the relationship to SQL so and
but for those of you who but certainly
just you know to summarize what they
just said look we have transformations
on sets of records you know the idea is
that you know we sort of we picked the
top you know the top 10 things that
people do with data right you join and
filter and project and so on right and
the idea is that ok these are you know
easy for users to use their extensible
you can only you know you can filter
according to some user-defined predicate
etc we've also of course chosen
primitives that we know how to paralyze
because the whole point here is that you
should not be able to write programs
that are slow if the data is big right
and just roughly I've shown you most of
the operators you have ones that take
one data set and produce a new one like
filtering
for each of the most common one that
just says apply some arbitrary
processing to each record to transform
it grouping is going to form subsets
right we also have operations that
combine multiple data sets so like join
I showed you Co grouping is another one
thats related to joined I'm not going to
go into in this talk union is like the
set Union you know so fine okay so
getting two ovens question yeah so
there's a bunch other languages that are
related and so let me talk about sequel
first yeah so certainly that the types
of operations you can express or the
start to a first approximation the same
a sequel there are some differences that
I'm not going to go into now but our
paper talks about that have to do with
nested data but at a high level yeah
it's the relational operators right join
and filter and whatnot so it's not the
so much the expressive power it's more
and that with sequel there's the strong
sense of its being declarative and the
user has no business knowing or
specifying how things are executed in
the system right that's the job of the
query optimizer okay and the idea is
that the quarry optimizer is going to
produce a very well chosen plan for how
to execute it okay so there's this
notion of separating those two layers
which sometimes works very well and
other times does not work as well so
with pig latin rather than so within
sequel you sort of so you specify this
bundle of constraints that are saying
the answer will have these properties
right but I'm not going to tell you how
to compute it with pig latin you're
giving a sequence of steps where each
step is transforming the data okay now
each step itself may be considered
declarative but you're giving the order
of the steps okay so it turns out that
um first of all just in terms of
programming style it feels a little bit
closer to imperative programming so like
if you're writing a Java program when
you have a sequence of steps for each
step gives you a new variable right and
and some people coming from sort of a
non sequel background find it easier to
understand this way of programming than
the sequel way of programming okay
brightly and with in sequence and thank
you see where it letting you need fixing
with something else so I / said rattling
you see the ability to get wealthy
programming languages yes you can go
high level population yes yes agree yeah
so I think dryad linked correct me if
I'm wrong to a first approximation its
sequel with a better integration with
higher-level languages and the ability
to compile down into a dryad okay so
yeah so the idea with pig latin is it's
you're specifying a data flow graph then
you can think of it as roughly analogous
to relational algebra as opposed to a
more calculus like expression with
sequel so that's the way yes the sequels
instead of a mother Deborah can't keep a
good stuff gets in or the team personnel
you know I'll Jimmy can exactly expose
what everything everybody does the after
passing in optimizer yes roughly that
the presentation yes yes yes when I'm
not you a pure database audience that's
usually what I say but yes okay examples
are shown and described them as
imperative but they look like pure
functional programs to be in the sense
that they always create a variable
whenever over it yes so again it's I
guess it's functional so from a database
perspective Davis people see the world
is having exactly two models there's
declarative and imperative but yes
you're right it's it's functional in the
sense that each one produces a new
variable you can overwrite variables and
yeah there's no side effects yes okay so
wait so there's really two distinction
from sequel one I mean well the
difference is it's really like
relational algebra and that gives you
two things one is that programmers who
are used to writing programs as
sequences of steps prefer that model and
I'm not just making this up like so
people actually tell me like look I
prefer just as a strictly a stylish to
get you nothing to do with performance I
prefer writing things in this way and
but the other issue is that your your
one level closer to
the execution compared with sequel so
you're it's you have more direct control
over what's happening and when you hear
two people sort of on blogs and so on
talking about why they like mapreduce
like when certain database people write
comments provocative comments about you
know the 2 i'm sure many of you have
read these blogs right why people will
say is well like I want to be assembling
pipes I don't want to be writing logic
constraints and so what we want to do is
retain the aspect from MapReduce where
you have these pipes but bring it up to
a higher level where you have these sort
of general data flows instead of the
sort of rigid two-step pipe that you
plunk down right okay any other
questions about this pig latin and
sequel distinction yeah so you if your
database person you can think of it as
relational algebra but there's some
secondary stuff that has to do with
nested data okay so okay so if you're
not a database person you might care
about this so how is this relate to
MapReduce so MapReduce is giving you a
data flow that has three sequence of
these steps right so you're saying I
want to process records individually I
want to form groups of Records and I
want to process groups right this is
called the map step this is called the
reduced step this middle part is
implicit so first of all look piglatin
subsumes this in the sense that you know
if you give me a program that structured
as a map function paired with a reduced
function i can write a simple pig
program that will give you the same
output you get with MapReduce so you
know so you're saying I have some input
so for each input I want to apply my map
function and then I want to form groups
according to so in in MapReduce all of
your records have two fields a key and
the value so in pig latin you can refer
the fields either by name or by position
so dollar zero is a way of referring to
the first field okay so I want to group
by the first field that comes from the
map function and and then for each of
the group's I want to apply my reduce
function okay so so certainly this
subsumes the MapReduce model and what
you're getting here is that in Pig I
mean you know each of the steps is
explicit they're in their independent
you can compose them however you want as
opposed to being stuck with this
sequence of three things in that
particular order okay and then on top of
that
you have put you know as I said you have
primitives for the things that people do
all the time of data like filtering
projecting combining multiple data sets
so I you know I would argue an hour
later I'll show you some of the numbers
that we're seeing in terms of usage at
yahoo but I think there's a much more
natural way to write programs then using
directly MapReduce and the other thing
is that because it's a higher-level
language there are more opportunities
for the system to be able to do some
optimizations so in terms of our
implementation right what we do we say
we have our pig system which you can
compile pig into local programs but and
people typically do that for debugging
but the real power of course is that you
want to run it on a cluster so we layer
pig on top of a Hadoop MapReduce which
is then running on potentially clusters
of thousands of machines and users of
course you know they're not blocked from
using MapReduce they can use MapReduce
directly or they can use pig I put the
sequel layer on top in parentheses we
don't have anything like that
implemented but it's not hard to imagine
that a layer like that will someday come
into existence right so I think in a
year you'll see that either from yahoo
or for some from somebody else and I
think there are good reasons to be at
each of these levels okay so so if
you're a database person you might yell
you know because they makes people
famously think everything is a database
and I'm a database person too so but if
you look at this you'll say oh well
though this you're building a database
right you'll say well right because if
you if you take you know Microsoft
sequel server or postgres or Oracle or
any of these systems and open them up
right if you look inside well yes the
the highest level is sequel but inside
that you'll have something that compiles
sequel into relational algebra trees
which to a first approximation is what
pig is and then underneath that you'll
have these sort of physical
implementations of the relational
operators which to a first approximation
that's what MapReduce is doing okay it's
doing group by and it's also giving you
a substrate that lets you do joins and
things like that ok so the right so the
question that I get from database people
and from myself is okay so are we
building another database system or is
this different I mean what I how does
this relate
ok so is is this a database system so i
don't think the answer is yes or no but
what I'm trying to do here is take for
interesting dimensions I'm not trying to
be exhaustive but I think these are four
important dimensions okay and so in
terms of the workload right and database
systems typically try to be very general
so rightly saying well look I'm going to
be able to deal with you know sort of
large bulk reads and writes and also
random reads and writes and all kinds of
different access patterns right and as
part of that I'm going to have all these
mechanisms right so to deal with random
reads i'm going to have indexes to make
those efficient and because i have
rights i have to worry about multiple
users or sort of concurrent users
stepping on each other's toes so i'll
have all these mechanisms to give you
nice properties in terms of concurrency
right transaction mechanisms so if you
look at pig and MapReduce on Hadoop and
those kinds of systems right what
they're doing is they're saying look I'm
going to handle a much more restricted
class of workloads i'm going to disallow
right so I'm gonna have a very very
constrained form of rights and I'm going
to focus on only sort of sequential
large sequential reads all right so
typically you're making one or more
complete passes over some large data set
right and you know so really what's
going on here is you're taking a slice
of the workload and you're trying to
make it you know especially scalable and
especially fault tolerant and all of
those things right so there's no magic
it's you always you see this all the
time in computer science right if you
work on a more specific problem you can
maybe do better in some dimension like
scalability for example right now in
terms of data representation right in
right in a database system there's this
notion of loading the data into the
database system so you give the database
system the data at that point you know
it sort of lives in the database system
and its controlled inside there right
and there are good reasons for that
because it makes transactions easier it
helps the database system do query
optimization I mean they're all kinds of
reasons why that's done right um but it
also means that there's a higher barrier
to actually do the processing right and
there are various implications of that
right and it also means that it's more
difficult to do
loosely structured data ok so the
certainly what's happening with with pig
and MapReduce and those kinds of systems
is look you know the data resides in
files and yes maybe they're distributed
files but the abstraction is a sequence
of bytes and yes the user will you know
at various times define various
structures on top of that but they're
not fixed to any one structure so
typically the structures are defined on
a need-to-know basis so you'll say yes
do this join and for the purpose of this
join here's the structure of the data
right just just go ok so it's a little
bit more freeform in that sense I
already mentioned this programming style
so DBMS typically deals with sequel
kinds of things we have a system of
constraints that define the answer right
here you have a sequence of steps and I
would argue that programmers are more
likely to prefer this model and lastly
right in terms of customized processing
yes you can express user-defined
functions in sequel sometimes it's very
awkward you have things that were like
the signature of the function determines
which of the sequel clauses the function
goes in and sometimes people have a hard
time reasoning about that and in Pig we
we sort of started with user-defined
functions and we designed the language
around that so they're very much
first-class citizens we also have the
ability to interoperate with legacy code
so you have some executable sitting
there that does face detection you don't
even have the source code anymore but
you know it works you just want to pump
data through it and you want to
interleave that with some more
structured operations like maybe joining
and filtering and with pig that's very
easy to express okay so any questions
about this characterization
any restrictions on the custom functions
not formally but if they have side
effects you might get weird things yeah
we should yeah in the back way this is
our know they are applicable when you
insurance yes and certainly for joins
there are cases where indexes can be
very valuable yeah now I'm not ruling
out indexing and the fact people are
working on indexes in this context like
HBase and things like that but what I'm
saying is if you just take the core
system right it's really it's what is it
good at its good at doing very large
sequential scans right and it's right
but there's a difference of approach
where here is more of a bottom-up
approach like let's let's stick the
things that we know we can do really
well and let's take that as far as we
can go whereas here it's more top-down
it's like let's define this very broad
set of things that you'd like to be able
to do and this very nice set of
properties like transactions and whatnot
and let's see how efficient we can make
it right so I think it's just sort of a
top down versus bottom up that doesn't
mean you can't add indexes to this world
and patent people will write over and
people are doing that okay
alright so sometimes people ask me how
do you actually run pig so I've shown
you like how to run it in PowerPoint but
so you know like you're actually sitting
at a computer and you wanna use pig what
you do so briefly I mean so typically
just if you're getting started you want
to play with it you can get the
interactive shell you get a little
carrot you start typing you load filter
whatever right if you're doing anything
serious you probably have your pig
script in a file and you just you give
it to Pig and pig runs it for you right
you can also embed pig in a host
language such as Java actually right now
it has to be Java but there's no
fundamental reason for that okay and you
would do this if you want things like
Turing completeness right you want loops
on the outside of your pig program so
for example you can implement pagerank
pagerank is about six lines of pig but
that's for one iteration so you need
some kind of a control loop on top of
that to do the iterations right there's
no fundamental reason you can't have
control loops in Pegasus we didn't
implement it okay this is actually it's
very rare that people actually need that
and we're also working on a graphical
editor to be able to sort of graphically
specify with the boxes and arrows
diagram a pig data flow okay so this is
a real thing we've implemented it it's
it's available an open source we have it
running on Hadoop or or you can run it
on your local machine people use that
for testing as I said okay it's you know
its production quality people are using
it for real stuff but it's also we know
there are some problems that we're
working on fixing so just a little
disclaimer this is being used quite
extensively at yahoo so at this point we
have hundreds of users collectively
submitting thousands of jobs per day
okay and recently we did a measurement
thirty percent of the Hadoop jobs that
are being run at Yahoo are coming from
pig okay and this is after less than a
year of pig being in production and the
number is increasing every month so it's
not that's not them it hasn't reached
its maximum I don't yeah so but so what
this means is that you know people are
jumping onto this relatively young
system you know because they're looking
for higher level abstractions and people
are saying that it's making them more
productive versus using rom MapReduce
sound of us another using laboratory yes
the remaining seventy percent are using
MapReduce directly yes yes so remember
this picture so pig well so this arrow
is a pig latin program and pig will
compile it into one or more MapReduce
programs okay it's okay to reduction do
you know an example that shows program
in the Met which is broken side by side
see I don't have an example off the top
of my head but I mean writing a joint
algorithm is at least a few hundred
lines of code and it's one line in pig
so and a lot of programs involved joints
at least 8 yahoo so a couple orders of
magnitude but you know but people cut
and paste those things so they're not
always writing them from scratch and it
depends how you want to measure it yeah
memory that's seventy percent versus 30
how curious in terms of payment option
how much had seventy percent for those
jobs our old jobs that just being
rewritten every day um I know it's more
than zero but I don't know the number
yeah so the question was some of these
jobs are maybe ad hoc processing but a
lot of them are probably sort of just
nightly jobs that are just run
systematically maybe run on new data
every night and so the question was some
of the seventy percent Hadoop jobs or
maybe just inertia from stuff that's
been running every night probably a lot
of it but I don't actually know yeah
okay so at this point in the talk I'm
going to start getting gradually more
and more into researching things so so
far I've been describing something
that's mostly just a practical thing
that you know it's sort of so it's
trying to get the best of both worlds
between the MapReduce kind of scenario
and SQL kind of scenario that works for
a large class of developers they like it
okay I don't think there's anything
especially deep about it yes
you said before the method should not
make updates but you don't check them
once we're checking dollars what sort of
error checking do we do right now we
actually don't do a lot of error
checking and that's one of the things
that we're trying to improve so I I'm
guarantee that dryad is way more power
ahead in terms of error checking and
things like that yeah so there's a team
of like six programmers working on and
error handling and error checking and a
lot of issues like that so it will get
better over time yep yeah so I should
mention some Pig started purely as a
research project and Yahoo research and
at this point it's purely a development
project so Yahoo researchers involved
but mostly we sort of handed it off and
we're working on other things so the
developers are much more likely to come
up with good ways of doing all of those
things especially since none of the
researchers or programming language
people okay so what I'm going to do now
is start talking about things that are
you know more research that we're still
working on and you know there's less
tested stuff so one of the things that
we'd like to have as a development
environment for this kind of thing right
so you can imagine I mean this is most
of this is like boilerplate stuff right
so you want some environment that tells
you what data is available it you know
gives you libraries of processing
elements things like that right and as
part of this you know sort of graphical
tool you can imagine ways of building up
pig programs other than textual
programming you can have sort of boxes
and arrows ways of specifying it and
along with that we can display example
data for you to help you build up your
program okay so this stuff is kind of
boring so I'm going to talk about this
stuff and give you some examples okay so
and this gives me sort of sneaky way to
give you another example of a pig
program so let's say we want to find
users who we have the same data sets
right the click login and the pinned the
page crawl and we want to find users who
tend to visit good pages so let's define
good as high page rank and let's say
let's say we want users who whose visits
are on average to high page rank pages
okay
so conceptually right here is sort of a
data flow that will give you this answer
right so a rectangle is some kind of a
you know it's either the source
rectangles are loading data and the
other rectangles of transformations the
arrows that represent sets of Records
okay so roughly you know this is sort of
isomorphic to that pig latin program i
showed you earlier rate you're saying
I'm loading the two data sets I'm
canonical izing the URLs I'm joining I'm
forming groups according to user for
each group i'm finding the average page
rank and I mean I'm filtering so I just
want the users whose average page rank
is above some threshold right so
hopefully this is fairly straightforward
so the question is so so you know I'm a
user I'm writing up some some kind of a
program like this is going to process a
large data set um how do I know that I
got it right I mean so I write something
like this and I want to run it over some
large data set right typically what
people do with not just with this kind
of programming but any kind of
programming is that you sent it well in
the old days before you know eclipse and
these dynamic checking things you send
it to the the compiler and they would
come back and say syntax error so you
fix all your syntax errors and then
eventually you'd actually run and but
they would crash or maybe would give you
the wrong answer and you did write many
times and eventually you'd get it to do
the right thing right so but the problem
is in this kind of environment where
fundamentally you're dealing with many
many terabytes of data these sort of
test runs is trial and error runs can
take a very long time right and just
think of all the like the carbon you're
admitting into the atmosphere by running
you know on a thousand machine data
center just to see if your programs
correct right so it would be nice if
there was some way that the tool could
help you reason about the behavior of
your program without having to actually
run it you know on the data center with
the full data right so so what what this
is showing you is the exact same data
flow program but now I'm annotating the
the arrows which represent these data
data sets with sample records right and
this is showing you you know if I had
this very tiny input like these three
clicks on those two web pages this is
would happen right so you're saying well
I I can see I canonicalize is going to
transform these URL strings like this
right and then I can see joining is
going to tack on this extra field so I
know the PageRank right I can see
grouping OIC grouping forms these nested
structures right I can see what you know
the average does and filtering and right
so I can sort of it makes it much more
concrete way of seeing what's happening
right so if you had say forgotten to do
the canonical eyes right then the join
result would be empty are you because
you'd be all right wouldn't be empty by
be smaller you'd have false negatives
right so it may in general you know
having concrete examples is always
easier than having abstract programs
right if you teach a class when you show
somebody a program you show them
examples right so the interesting
question from a research point of view
is can we generate these gray rectangles
these example records automatically okay
so so you might think oh yeah fine
that's easy right i just use sampling oh
I'll sample the inputs and I'll just
push it through the data flow and I'll
get some sampled outputs and all the
intermediate results right but the
problem is that in general that won't
work very well because sometimes you
have operations like this join here
where if you take a random sample of
each of the inputs chances are the join
will not have any matches if the domains
are large right or in general any kind
of selective operator like you have a
selective filter right sampling may you
may get empty stuff down here right so
so that that's not going to work um oh
yes sergeant what is it what are you
just one no good
I mean I don't need to know anything yes
so what you like the same time talking
or random samples so is there a specific
criteria yeah so it's unfortunate it's a
little difficult to state crisply but
let's assume that the the core
algorithms are correct like I'm trusting
that the pig developers implemented
joint correctly so what I'm doing is now
I'm building my data flows by using
these building blocks and composing them
right so I'm stacking the group and then
the transform in the filter and I just
want to be able to reason about the
behavior of the the composed program I
just want to understand things like you
know I got this canonicalize function
under the library but i just want to see
like what does it do right and the
easiest way to see that is by looking at
examples right or right so or grouping
so grouping I'm assuming it's
implemented correctly but I don't
understand the scheme of the output like
right in pig with grouping we had we
give you a nested output right so if
you're new to pig or you new to the
grouping operator you may not be very
familiar with that so if I show you
example data then you can see all I see
it's going to create this nested
construct right so it's just in general
it's easier to write a query or a data
flow if you can see examples of what the
intermediate data looks like you could
see what inside of the schema you
actually see data right so the idea is
just to give you data to illustrate what
this thing looks like one scenario is
that you're trying to build this thing
and make sure that it does what you
intended another scenario is that
somebody else built it and they left the
company and then you get handed this
thing and you want to understand what
does it do so yeah there's this program
it does something with data I don't
understand right so no it's not specific
to pagal there's any sort of data
centric paradigm yeah yeah yeah so you
could do it in tioga or whatever yeah
right so okay so yeah so i drew these
boxes by hand but how would you generate
these automatically I think that's an
interesting question sampling the
straightforward sampling doesn't work
very well so the second thing you might
try as some kind of reverse reasoning
you say well
find so sampling might give me empty
results so what I'll do is I'll I'll try
to make you know put in some constraint
at the bottom it says I need some some
record here that passes this filter and
then I'll sort of work backwards and try
to populate things at the top right so
the problem with that is the main
problem with that is you have these
functions these non-invertible functions
so if you want to do backwards reasoning
and you encounter a function that the
user gave you as a black box you don't
really know how to go backwards through
that function right so so I think
there's this interesting research
problem here with the the sort of naive
approaches don't work very well right
and you want to generate this data right
the in terms of so it's a little bit
difficult to characterize the objectives
but I I think roughly speaking you want
these three kinds of things and I have
ways to quantify these that you know in
a paper that we're working on but
roughly speaking you want you want the
data to be realistic in the sense that
if I showed you some data those
isomorphic to this but had XYZ it
wouldn't be very helpful right so you
want the data to resemble real data now
that's different from saying that it has
to be real data right and that's
actually very important because right
the fact that you know CNN com has a
pagerank of point nine is not important
for this particular exercise so I can
make up a pagerank value right so you
can do some games with synthesizing data
but should at least resemble real data
let me go through the metrics and then
I'll take your question the second one
is sort of obvious to concisely I don't
want each of those boxes to have 10,000
records I wanted to have a handful of
records right and completeness roughly
says I don't want empty boxes I want to
illustrate all of the results you have a
question I can see that sampling for a
lot of deer set of phrases all the
bother to mention like if you work is
that your work in a company and you look
at your internal web were you
the internal web inside anything it gets
smaller in her right before you go to
the web go in the microsoft internal
what was it or the yahoo internal web or
even better on the bag of research
internal web or the yoga fakira internal
web right now after line it's rinks and
either hundreds only a hundred times
smaller than the web you'll save
ninety-nine percent of the money yes so
well just to be clear I mean the
scenario here is that work that we have
the entire web in a yahoo data center we
weren't doing processing over that but
yes I mean that fundamentally way if you
want to use sampling you want to be able
to jointly sample from two things where
you're likely to find matches so if you
know enough about the data set you might
be able to do that but in general right
treating it as a black box you have some
operations you have some data that you
don't know anything about you don't know
how to do that sampling in the back
connection to the high school people
have this tool called Quinta that's
pretty similar to be sure it's
generating automatically it's turning
this from compare the specifications of
what the evils yes yes um I like to see
if you can send me a link to that um so
there's a there's plenty of work in soft
automated software verification and also
hardware some of it has a similar flavor
usually the goal is a little bit
different so here the idea is that you
have some input data set so all of the
software verification stuff that I've
encountered maybe your case is different
but it's sort of working in the abstract
but here the idea is you want to
actually come up with example data that
sort of roughly conforms to some data
that you're actually given right and
they so you work off of that and you're
trying to illustrate all of the
intermediate steps right so you're
trying to produce sort of realistic and
concise examples for each intermediate
step and I don't think there's work in
software verification but has that
flavor but I could be wrong so if it'd
be great if you could send it to me one
data
the whole flow of the network but it
seems like you're describing in the case
of that joint example and documentation
that should have come along with that
primitive operator in which case
couldn't you just package with it some
sample data so when you click on this
link you see you cry to be fine
interactive sometimes people forget to
do that box then there shouldn't miss
bit can't afford description and said
this is how the sets of life sure um
yeah so in an ideal world you know
everything is extremely well documented
and you know people supplied these
examples along with all of their code in
reality I don't think that's really the
case and even if they do they could be
wrong and so you'd like to test it right
but yeah you're right i mean so maybe
yeah maybe people will start doing that
we won't need any kind of automated
software yeah whole system message you
up yeah we girls out testing the data
range cuz web data is pretty gonna make
you wanna see when the crazy should
happen yeah that's right yeah so maybe
we're fine on one web crawlers sort of
did some cleaning but there's a new web
crawl that doesn't do the cleaning and
it breaks breaks what you're trying to
do yeah yeah um ok so anyway sorry I'm
trying to sort of go breadth-first in
this talk I so we have some ideas about
how to solve this problem at this point
I'm just trying to introduce the problem
and just argue that it's an interesting
problem in that you know sort of simple
solutions don't necessarily work very
well okay so we have ways of thinking
about formalizing this and applying
algorithms so but i do want to leave a
little bit of room for one last topic
which is sort at the implementation
level right we we have these these data
flow programs and we have this language
and as far as executing them what there
are various optimizations you can do
most of them are the sort of boring
database optimizations that have been
done for decades there's i think there's
room to do well but let me let me get
into the the slides and talk about
optimizing ensembles of programs so
before i get there just so people are on
the same page
the way that the system works is that a
pig latin program comes in ok we have a
parser just like you know standard stuff
we compile a pig widen program into what
we call an execution plan which if
you're not a database person right it's
some kind of a tree of algorithms that
are processing data starting from raw
data that's stored on disk and producing
a sort of series of derived data sets
right and then we have a second compiler
that takes something like this and
compiles it into one or more MapReduce
jobs ok and roughly speaking the
objective of this one is just to
minimize the number of MapReduce jobs
because each MapReduce job is a pass
over the data ok roughly speaking and
then we we use Hadoop as our MapReduce
implementation to actually run this on
the cluster ok so what I'm going to talk
about for the rest of the talk is
something that we're working on to put
inside our compiler which we call our
cross job optimizer ok so instead of
taking one job at a time and compiling
and optimizing it we're going to look at
ensembles of multiple related jobs so
let me start by motivating why this is
important right so first of all I get me
if you look at what people are doing
with with MapReduce and pig at Yahoo and
I suspect it's very similar at Microsoft
and at Google you know that we have a
lot of tables in our system data sets
but there's only a few of them where
most of the action happens right there's
like the web crawl and the cliq logs and
you know the search search logs are what
people are searching for like Britney
Spears as you all know right and and so
you have a lot of action on these these
these handful of very large data sets
and if you look at the way these
MapReduce systems are processing these
right they have a queue like you know a
FIFO queue or maybe a smarter queue of
pending requests and at any given time
the system is handling one or two of
those requests the request to sort of
this thing where you scan this very
large data set and you do some
processing sometimes the processing
you're doing is fairly complex and
expensive like face detection a lot of
times is very cheap processing like
you're counting something like how many
times did Britney Spears occur on the
web right so in those cases the sort of
the work is mostly I oh
like most of the resources are going
into just doing the scans right and so
what you have is a queue of jobs I'll
you know half of them waiting to scan
the same thing that the current job is
scanning right and so you're doing the
skin of these files over and over again
each time to do one jobs or the
relatively simple processing right so
there's an obvious opportunity though to
amortize the scan across many jobs right
and the same is true if you look not
just at the data that's being accessed
but also the way the data is being
transformed you see the same
transformations over and over again wait
so and in fact so things like okay I
want to process the web but I want to
filter out the spam right or I want to
do groupwise host wise processing of web
pages instead of one URL at a time right
so when I first got to yahoo I wanted to
run a bunch of processing on the web and
I asked somebody that I knew in the
development group hey can you send me
some code or something that will suck
the web out and let me process it and he
gave me code that did a bunch of stuff
like this and you said Oh paste your
part at the end right so you know yeah
you you you want to eliminate spam a
group by host and then do some
processing right so you have people
independently submitting these jobs that
have a common prefix and obviously
there's redundant work going on right so
we want to try to minimize that work
right so in databases is called multi
query optimization you can roughly think
of three kinds of techniques that you
can use to try to minimize redundant
work one of them is you can you can take
jobs that are similar meaning perhaps
they access the same data set and you
can run them jointly instead of running
them separately so you only do the scan
of the data set once and then you do the
processing after that all right so you
save one scan of the data set a second
kind of thing you can do is you can say
well look I've got these two jobs that
have some common prefix like both of
them filter the spam and group by host
and so to avoid you know doing that same
work multiple times I'm going to cash
some intermediate result like I'm going
to catch a prime which is dry it drive
by applying operator 12 a it's on
databases this is called the
materialized view okay
and the third kind of thing you can do
remember underneath all of this we have
a parallel system running on many
machines right so the data lives on many
machines processing is occurring on many
machines so sometimes you have
situations like this where you've got
these data blocks ABCD spread across
these worker nodes right and when you
have some kind of processing you have to
do that has to get scheduled somewhere
right so for example maybe you know
maybe worker one is really busy because
people are scanning d and you have some
requests that requires processing a and
B together right so maybe that gets
scheduled over here right because this
this machine is idle right so in order
to make this happen right a has to get
copied over here at least temporarily so
that you can perform this operation
right so here you have an opportunity to
you know if you believe that there's
some stationary in the workload we're
combining a and B is going to be a
common thing like maybe a and B a
related data sets that get joined often
then it may make sense to have a and B
co-located together you know going
forward in the future right so you can
think about the placement of the data
with respect to the workload that you're
seeing okay so let's see so I I guess I
want to wrap up because it's been almost
an hour but from a database perspective
most of these techniques are not new
okay and I'm not really so much
interested in the mechanisms here okay
what I'm interested in is the process of
deciding when to apply these techniques
okay so you have these think about
having a sort of a MapReduce Pig kind of
system that has these weapons right you
can use these things to avoid doing
redundant work avoid redundancy ands or
avoid redundant transformations or avoid
redundant data movements in the cluster
so the question is when would you apply
these things and I think at a high level
the kinds of ways that database systems
tend to think about deciding when to
apply these things are not always going
to succeed in in this kind of
environment because of the nature of the
jobs they tend to be much more opaque in
general then database kinds of jobs
they have someone used to define
processing elements and also because of
the nature of the environment you have
this much more chaotic environment with
thousands of machines some of which are
up some of which are down and you have
you know the network saturation is sort
of moving around the bottlenecks are
shifting so the sort of so what I'm
interested in is rather than looking at
approaches based on sort of modeling and
planning to decide when to apply these
techniques looking at approaches are
more adaptive that for applying these
techniques so I can talk in more detail
about that but just you know so to avoid
having the talk take a long time maybe
I'll just skip to the end so okay so
I've gone through a lot of things just
let me go back and summarize the main
points here so so I started by talking
about a data parallel language which
would call pig leiden and the idea is
that users are specifying these sort of
general sequences of of transformations
on data okay and they can use a
combination of standard relational style
primitives as well as interleaving that
with custom code I talked about a
development environment where users can
develop their programs and the
interesting thing there from the
resource perspective was can you
automatically generate example data to
illustrate how the data flow is going to
transform the data through the
intermediate results okay and then at
the end I talked a little bit about
runtime optimizations so in particular
given that you have a set of related
programs how can you amortize the work
that's being done redundantly in those
programs and obviously I'm not doing
this work by myself a bunch of people
working on this so these are my
colleagues and glad to take any last
questions that people have
so what I probably see if this doesn't
the distributor PI system take care of
it in a short time certainly so it takes
care of yeah so the distributed file
system right makes the location of these
blocks transparent to the thing that's
executing so the fact that you're trying
to join a and B here but a doesn't have
a local copy right it'll automatically
take care of fetching a from somewhere
else right how do we supposed to be good
at the operation takes place on the look
at it and the look at its mission look
at it is you can do yes for but it's
seema doom is very much fixated on
operations that have one input but in
practice people who joins all the time
right and so here it tell me how to do
the joint such as a and B are both local
that you can't but if you anticipate
that joining a and B is going to be a
common thing over you know repeated over
time perhaps you should think about
reorganizing the data such they and be
our local right and then even more
sophisticated can say well look I have
three copies of a and three copies of B
because that's how i'm doing fault
tolerance so maybe some of the pairs are
local and some of them are not right and
so you can there's all kinds of
interesting games you can get into and
you can think about those sort of static
ways of planning that and also adaptive
ways of doing it right this organizer
optimization to take please take place
at make people take care of it or should
i do people you can make the argument
for either way I don't think the
optimization is specific to peg but peg
makes it easier to express join so
you're more likely to encounter them
yeah
you make MapReduce and data flows
synonymous with these two this work I
wonder if you would get any leverage out
of using more general forms of data for
a bit then you know which are many
different types so if you wanted for
example it to have a control loop you
can use the Nexus of a version of data
but it's no longer just MapReduce where
you can even analyze a system for the
dead log or introduce five votes between
the links and no fighting between the
link yeah so in between passing data
these icing these are finite links
between the notes right thing of the
past them data to the other no that's
hungry and so if you have too much data
you overflowed this link and then the
system does something that there's
completely different from MapReduce at
that point so more general all I'm
saying is that they're more general data
flow languages out there that's it go
beyond that model yeah and can provide
additional sure so what if you remember
from earlier as I was saying that so pig
is fundamentally a directed acyclic data
flow so it does not allow cycles we have
so far encountered exactly one case
where people wanted cycles which was for
a pagerank computation and iterative
computation and we have the embedding
property so you can embed in a
programming language that has control
loops so of course then doing
optimization across the levels is going
to be hard so um so far it doesn't seem
like in practice for us at least there's
a lot of motivation for looking at doing
complicated sort of optimization of
control structures in Pig just because
we haven't encountered a lot of people
who need those kinds of control
structures perhaps as as users get more
sophisticated they'll start wanting more
and more that I don't know at this point
but one thing that's actually important
to point out is the way that pig does
the execution is what we call lazy
execution so the way you specify pay
program is you give it a sequence of
steps right which have which can refer
to variables defined in previous steps
and there's a special command called
store which says take a variable and
materialize it on disk pig will not
actually do anything
then parse your program until you say
store okay and the reason we can get
away with that is because the data is
basically static we don't deal with
updates right but the advantage of doing
that is we can do optimization of large
fragments of programs and where this
ties together your question in the
PageRank example where you have a loop
in Java that's spinning out Pig commands
right you'll see actually assuming you
know in advance how many iterations you
want to do or you maybe you want to do
10 iterations and then check for
convergence we can actually optimize
across all 10 iterations so effectively
we're doing loop unrolling right so we
can get some of the advantages for free
sometimes I don't know if it pertains to
your question or not but yeah would have
it lazily well you can think of both I
think both are interesting and certainly
in the database world you've seen plenty
of work on these mechanisms for doing
what yet so for selecting materialized
views in fact Sarah jet has done a lot
of network and data placement sort of in
the sort of planning stage right you're
populating the database you have some
anticipated workload or maybe
periodically you look at the workload
and you try to optimize based on that
and I think that makes a lot of sense
I'm interested in looking at well can
you in addition to that can you do
things that are more adaptive right as
so as conditions are changing you're
seeing different you know work load
characteristics or maybe you knew about
the workload was going to be but you
didn't have a good model for what how it
was going to behave until you actually
ran it right so maybe sort of reactively
I try to adjust your plants in terms of
what thing what data you're caching or
where the data is being located so and I
think that's where there's more room for
interesting research that hasn't been
done already thank our speaker okay
you